il y aura un poissard puisque c'est très
simple à chaque fois la personne va
prendre un ingrédient haut et va le
mettre dans ce mixeur et ensuite à lire
à chercher une carotte
ici l'eau celui qui aura la plus petite
carotte de voix brard tout le mix and
away we made you lie non non c'est qui
va se faire
julien m'a dit julien tu penses que tu
veux comme ingrédients et tu le mets
dedans déjà ce que notre conscience que
c'est très bon voilà voilà pour le
transit la commande à l'éval 28 pas dire
qu'on va maintenant très bien qu anne
frèches effet et julien tu vas prendre
une carotte le prendre car je la tire
bien sûr tu tires la carotte plutôt
habilement une bosse ça fait longtemps
qu'on ne l'avait pas vu
[Rires]
alors il fallait pas dire la dette
allez on va dire voilà a pas obligé de
céder sa fille on est obligé de citer
d'autres crème chocolatée mont blanc et
autres
merci sédégo allez c'est parti ben aziza
tu prends tout de suite d'apprendre la
carotte c'est toujours nous et pour
noisiel carottes souvenirs récents cgil
a mis un quart d'heure c'est un petit
peu trop mal choisie comme massive a
terminé une carotte qui l'ignoble
choisissez bien
mais du temps je regarde ces carottes
comme dans la vie c'est bon c'est bien
sûr c'est qu'annie pour l'instant c'est
toujours à prendre juste c'est choisir
l'accès de l'avocat ne crois pas qu'on a
tous à tous les partis bannissez un
accès je rappelle que celui qui devra
boire l'ensemble du mixeur vas-y c'est
maxime pjanic mais là on l'attend tu te
mets là vous avez des 46 mattotti du mix
est là et tu mets ta carottes bien
entendu je suis moins intelligent ou
tard alors allez chercher votre carte
pour l'instant c'est maxime guennic est
la plus petite carotte
vous vous en doutiez chez vous allez
[Musique]
c'est bon ça sent bon maxime elodie
fontan qui est avec nous la pauvre elle
était venue en amie ça met un peu de
sucre et le gars qui va voir ça ou la
fille faire passer des lois attention
attention elodie choisissait il reste
quatre joueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention je vous rappelle il ya plus
comment grâce aux deux tireurs ayé de
tir williams ont également attention à
ce que vous allez avoir une petite
carotte qu'elodie directeur et enfin je
vais mettre un petit peu de vinaigre
mes amis je crois je suis plus petits
gâteaux
on attend derrière leur ghana s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît on triche pas
attention ne triche pas on mesurera les
carottes essentielle et cyril reste à
mon coeur souvent les gens qui sort
vraiment réussi récompense quelque chose
qui en faisons quelques des petites
carottes et la famille les ennemis
passer leur chance et pas vous voulez
tirer
elle a été raccourcie la mienne on n'a
pas ça soit très berger dire la plus
petite
c'est la plus fine oui elodie là désolé
de te le dire mais tu as la plus petite
carotte alors à temps mais perd un
dernier truc je vais faire un dernier
truc fifi je vais mixer
et après je vous dirais l'émission a
commencé là malheureusement sardines
danet tard force est bien quand même phi
phi phi phi tu te rajoute un peu de moi
c'est quoi ça change tout la petite
fille tu sais que tu es un ami il va le
faire depuis des années je le croyais
pas bien fait
tu as bien fait deux ou trois petites
filles mettre face à ses responsabilités
soit tu dis oui je vais boire ce vert
forêt tu dis pas oui papa sever j'ai
fait appel à un ami qui est mon estomac
il m'a dit voilà faisait je fais ici
[Applaudissements]
grand chose vous êtes un ami et pourquoi
lui fait le malin mais petit à leur tour
où est la promo la famille n'a pas non
plus pour une fois ça tombe sur la
gueule dérapages fait fort qu'elle n'a
pas là non ça voilà le cocktail je vais
en boire un peu bas si eva joly bah oui
je suis obligé je vais en boire un peu
plus que j'avais promis confie aller
franchement je vois le bret
c'est horrible basse a offert trouve
lundi les chiffres australe en direct de
mossel bay stocks mais quelle horreur
mais vous pouvez pas savoir si c'est si
oui accordez-moi 30 secondes venait avec
moi samedi à 14h30 au stade de france et
la plus grande dictée du monde organisée
par rachid santaki aller a dit merci le
coeur
[Applaudissements]